サッバパパッサアカラナン クサラッサウパサンパダ サチッッタパリオダパナン エタングブッダナサーサナン
ではよろしくお願いします
今日のテーマはあまり難しいことはないんです
内容は全部なんか宣伝文句に書いてありましたからね
それはコピー文句としてはね
最低の書き方でしたけどね
まあだから私の喋るものは何もないんです
全部書いてありましたから
それを読んでください
読み読んだことある方々はどうぞご自由に
コピーを書く場合はね
次はどうなっているのかというね
心の興味を表れないと
はい まあ一応まあ面白くないとは思いますけど
あまり難しくもないんですね
過去から解放というテーマで少々喋っています
早く終わりますから 皆様のいろいろ自由な質問を出してみてください
はい 副題はなぜ今しっかり歩けないのかと
はい まず一般論でいきます
一般人は過去というのはすごく大事なことだと思っているんですね
過去の経験を生かせなくてはならないと思っているんですね
当たり前ですね 経験豊かな人は役に立つと思っていますね
それで過去なんです 経験というのは過去だからね
お調子者がね 過去を忘れたことにすると
だから過去を忘れましたと言ったら
かなり信頼されませんね
これは一般世界の考えなんですね
過去を忘れてしまうことは病気で危険ですね
俗世間はそう思っているんです
忘れちゃったと あんた大変に大丈夫？ということになっちゃうんです
人を信頼する前に過去を調べるべきです
これもよくあることでね
何者かと過去を調べてから信頼するかしないかということは決定するんですね
人の過去とはその人の人格です
俗世間ではそう思っているんですね
人の過去の流れがその人の人格ですと
だから世間では過去というのはもうかなり大事なもので
呼吸と同じく欠かせない考えになっているんです
それは皆様知っていることだからね
じゃあ次できます はい
これから仏教的な話になります
で 過去っていうのはちょっと分析してみましょう
これは一般人がやらないことですから
ここからブッダの世界なんですね
過ぎ去った時間ではありません
過去っていうのは ただ時計でいう過ぎ去った時間数字ではないんですね
みんな一応そう勘違いしているんです
何年何月ですかとかね
何日何秒ですかとかね
これ 時間じゃないんです
人が生きてゆく流れが過去なんです
だから何を何をやったのかと
この行為のレポートなんですね
過去っていうのは 時間じゃないんです
まあ一応時間のハンコは押すんだけど
それによって許されるか許されないかとかね
まあ例えば10歳の子がその時やったことが形でもやる場合は
まあちょっとこれは許せないというような
認められないということになっちゃうんですね
だから ある行為はある年齢で認められる
ではしかし 同じ行為は年齢が変わったら認められないといろいろありますね
ですから 我々は仮にタイムスタンプを引くんで押すんです
例えば 3人で仲間で万引きしちゃったと
ここでタイムスタンプを押してみたら
10歳ですね あるいは11歳とかね
それでまた一人が万引きしたんだと
これでタイムスタンプを押してみたら
45 5歳 同じじゃないんです
その場合は   子供やったくない
お前ら何やってるのかいい加減にしろよっていうことで終わっちゃうんですね
親が謝って まあそれで終わっちゃいます
でも 45歳 タイムスタンプは 45 になっちゃうと
万引きっていうのはかなり犯罪ということになっちゃうんですね
はい とにかく仏教的に理解しててほしいのは
この行為の流れなんです
タイムスタンプじゃないんですね
気になるのは私の過去です
歴史的過去ではありません
そこで私たちは 私の過去
私の過去ということはえらく気になるんですね
しかし あのタイムスタンプを押した行為の流れはそれほど気にしない
なんか変なんです 生まれてきてから今までいろんなことをやって生きてきたんですね
それそれ一個一個すべてのレポートを取ったら自分の過去なんですけど
それってあまり関係ないんですね
なんか別に私の過去という気になる過去があるんですね
起きた出来事は過去で変えることはできない事実です
次に覚えてください 起きたことが終わったんです
それはもうどうすることもできない
だから過ぎ去ったんです
そういうものは事実になるんですね
で 何て言いますか 時間を戻して何とかすることはできません
客観的なデータである事実は問題を起こしません
そこで この客観的に過去で起きた出来事は
人間としては何の問題も起こしません
問題を起こすこともできません
もうないんだから 今は
こういうところでいろいろたとえ話
例を出さなくちゃいかんだけどね
なかなかいらんでしょう
もうわかってることだからね
例えば何年何月で地震が起きたとする
昔 まあ五 六年前でもいいんです
今更関係ないんです たとえ津波が来ても
例えば 1年前津波があったとしましょう
今は津波にどうすることもできません
今あるのは津波が起きて 1年経過した時の結果なんです
その 1年の間でかなり復興作業起きちゃって
新しい建物を作ったりして
新しい世界が現れてるんです
それでも 1年前で津波が起きたんだから
今苦しいって言っちゃうと
これ変ですね 今も怖いと言っちゃうと変なんですね
去年の津波は怖いですよと
それは変です 去年起きた津波はもう終わっちゃったんです
今 何の影響も与えることはできません
ですから それ 悪い例で良い例でも同じなんですよ
あの 私はね  40年前で超美人でしたと
結婚するときは だから何よと
それアルバム持ってみんなに自慢したっても
かえって悪い結果になるんですよ
今 今の時点時期で 時点で普通のばあちゃんだよと
あんた何か食べなかった
食べてないんだったら
料理でも作ってあげましょうという状態でいた方が幸せなんです
あんた見る？これ これ私の 40年前ですけど
結婚時の写真やと だから過去の史実には
これは史実ですよ この今言ったおばあちゃんが
もう40年前はものすごい美しい方であった
それは問題ない 写真まであるんだから
でも今更それは何の影響もないんです
無効です もう死んじゃった出来事なんです
だから無能で無効なんです
それは人間に理解できないんですね
例えば 誰かが石を投げて私の頭に石を投げちゃうと
私の頭に当たって怪我する
それは現代の石であるならばなんです
今現在の石 今どなたか石を投げなくちゃいけないんですよ
そういう気持ちでいるから行ったんですよ
で しかし えーと  12月2日投げた石が今当たって怪我するということはありえないんですね
12月2日で投げた石はそこら辺落ちちゃって
もう終わりなんですね
だから変な人々はね だってまあもう 100年前の出来事でもね
宇宙で起きたものは今見れる
見えるでしょうとかね
それは過去ではないかと
違います 今 自分の機械に
テレスコープに入ったデータをシミュレーションしているだけなんです
だからまあそれだけのことなんです
過去のデータを見ているとか何とか言っても
これってちょっとおかしいんです
推測するんで この光がもう100年 100
年前で発進したものであると
でもそこは証拠はないしね
とにかく宇宙でいろいろ組み立ててる
変なくだらない あれ いろんな機械で何かデータを感知して
そこでシミュレーション画像を作ってるんですね
過去のものはもう死んじゃうんですね
死んじゃって別なものになるんです
だからこの科学者言ってる宇宙環境をやっている人々も
もうちょっと考え直した方がいいんですね
ものは変化して変化して流れるんです
同じものをずっと来てぶつかるわけじゃないんで
史実を感情で調理するとすべての問題が起きます
ここがポイントなんです
過去に起きた出来事を私たちは処理するんです
自分好みの感情で 怒り
嫉妬 憎しみ 恨み あれやこれやとか
いろんなもう美味しい材料を入れて料理するんです
かなりごちそうを作るんです
その結果が 人に大変な問題を引き起こすんです
あの普通の料理と同じなんですよ
自然のものを食べたら
何の病気にもなりません
我々はもう慣れてしまって
昔からね 自然なものを食べません
不自然でなければと だから茹でたり
焼いたり 揚げたり もう大体10回ぐらいいろんな過程を経て料理するんですね
電子レンジでやって またオーブンに入れて
またやって また油入れて
またあれやこれやとかね
あの料理したものが我々の健康を壊しちゃうんですね
だからこの油そのものはそんなに体に問題は起こしません
例えばナッツを食べる
ナッツにすごい油がありますよ
すごい油のようなんですね
ナッツ食べたからといって
コレステロール上げたく取ってはないんですね
しかし ピーナッツで油を取り出して
あのピーナッツ油で魚揚げちゃうと
これは食べない方がいいんです
しかし 美味しいんだからみんなやってるんですね
だからこれは料理の授業じゃないね
忘れちゃった で 理論的には自然なものは体に何の悪い影響も与えません
我々は自然な材料を料理する
それから体の健康は心配しなくちゃいけない
手術は起きた出来事は人に何の迷惑もかけません
起きた出来事をいくつか選んで料理するんです
感情で怒り 嫉妬 憎しみ
恨み 興奮 舞い上がり 楽しみ
あれやこれやとかね で
感情で料理する場合は
事実を適当に選ぶんです
だってこの料理に合うものしか入れてはいけませんでしょ
例えば ある人がじゃあチキンカレー作ろうと
そうすると どんなチキンでもなく
カレー用のぶす切りにしたチキンを持ってきて
いろいろして じゃあこちらについでにうなぎの蒲焼も入れましょうかと
入れませんよ カレーがコトコト煮てきて
食べ頃になってくると
面白いんだから蒲焼も入れましょうやと
入りませんね ハチャメチャになっちゃうんです
だから料理するときはどんな材料もいいわけじゃないでしょ
材料を選択しなくちゃあかんです
だから我々は過去の事実を感情で調理するときは選択するんです
これとこれだけ取りましょうと
他のはいらないと 他のデータを忘れちゃうんですね
はい それから料理したら
体の健康を心配しなくちゃあかんでしょ
手術を調理したら 精神の健康が心配しなくちゃいけないんです
精神が病気にかかるんです
だけだからいい加減な思い出ですよ
我々のあるのは 人は客観的に正しくデータを記憶しません
頭の中が壊れているんです
貪瞋痴の 感情を引き起こした経験
喜び 楽しみ 感動などを与えたもののみを忘れないように記憶に入ります
長い文章ですね でも意味は簡単です
私は何を覚えているんですかね？私の過去で
何か起きたら私は怒りました
その時 で 何か出来事が起きた
あの出来事の結果 私は怒っちゃった
怒ったらあの出来事を覚えておく
何か私がやった そこで周りは私を褒めた
ああ よかった よかった
すごいですね とかね そうすると
あの出来事を私は忘れないように覚えておく
そのように我々はこの感情の
何といいますかね 感情を引き起こしたもの
で感情付けになったデータだけ覚えている
ある女性に聞いたんだ
あなたの人生でね 一番幸せを感じた時はどんな時ですか？と
その方言ったのは あの子供が子供を産んだ時やと
そこで今 その私にその話をするときは
自分の子供はもしかすると二十歳も飛んでいるかもしれませんだけど
しかし その方には 自分が若い時
子供を産んだ経験がまだそのまま覚えているんですね
いつでも頭で再現できる
なぜならば その時すごい幸せを感じたんですね
それも感情の一つなんですね
感情の場合はね もう悪い感情も良い感情もありますよ
だから幸せ感じることは悪い感情じゃないんです
喜び 楽しみ感じることが悪感情じゃないんですよ
怒り 嫉妬 憎しみ 恨み あれやこれやとかね
そういうのは まあ欲とかね
すごい破壊的な感情なんですね
こちら貪瞋痴と書いたんだから
そちらの反対の感情もある
貪るんじゃなくて 人を助ける気持ち
それも感情ですけど まあ良い感情ですね
で 怒るんじゃなくて 慈しむ気持ち
慈しむ気持ちも感情です
しかし それはとても良い感情なんですね
そういうわけで 善であろう
悪であろうと関係なく
感情がガクンと上がった行為だけ覚えているんです
他は忘れるんです だから
学校で学ぶ客観的なデータなんかは
これ知識でしょ ものの見事に忘れちゃうんです
なんのことなくもう忘れちゃったと
授業なんかは真剣に聞いてるんだけど
椅子から立ったらもう忘れてるんです
その例えをお釈迦様がこのデータをこの膝の上に乗せると例えているんですね
人間がいるんだよと 真剣に話を聞いてますけど
このデータを全部膝の上に溜めるんだと
で 立ちったら全部ドカンと
そういうわけで  小中高大学などなどで学んだ知識はあまり日常生活では使いませんね
だから過去を生かしてないんです
感情で固定したいい加減なデータ
だって選んだんだから
調理するために 自分好きな調理をしたいんですね
だから過去というのはずっとたくさんデータがあるのに
いくつか選ぶ 選ぶんです
で 子供に見ても 子供さえも興奮させないと勉強しないんですよ
感情的に だから子供に何か教えたければ
何か覚えて欲しければね
まあ数学でもしっかり理解して欲しければ
いろんなもう からくりやってね
子供をちょっと楽しくさせるんですね
興奮させちゃうんです
そうすると 興奮と一緒にデータが覚えておくんです
はい そこでなんでこんなこと起きるのかと
これってバカでしょ？例えば
生まれてからまあ 50歳まで生きてきたとしましょう
その人は過去のいくつかのデータしか覚えていない
例えば  50歳でもいまだに親を恨んでいると
そういう人がいるんですよ
親のことを恨んでいる
だから親を恨むために
親との関係は 50年も続いてるんだけど
一つ 二つ 三つぐらいデータを取るんです
取って恨みで調理する
調理して親 親っていうのはもう悪人的悪魔やと
親を裏切る人間になる
これって変ですね 親との関係は零歳時からもうずっとあるんです
親が悪人だったら こいつはもう一歳になる前に死んでるんです
小学校に行くまでは命はもちませんよ
ですから まあスーッと親のお世話いただいて
親の愛情があって育てられたのに
ちょっと変なことをやったところで
まあいい加減なことをやったところで
親も人間だから疲れますよ
その時ガーッと怒鳴ったりはする
もう厳しい言葉まで言う
お前なんか産まなかった方がよかったとかね
言うかも でもそちらに全然何の意味もないんです
そんなこと言われたって
ただ 母親が今やったことに対してカンカン怒ってるんですよ
それも子供のことを愛してるから怒っちゃったんですね
でも ものすごい問題があまりにも大きくちゃって
親母親にももうどうすることもできない
そこで腹が立って お前なんか産まなかった方がよかったと
言うかも それぐらいその言葉を言うのは
繰り返し繰り返し悪いことをする時ですよ
一回やっただけでは言いません
それで このバカが自分やったことは全部チャラにしちゃって
母がおっぱいあげたことも全部チャラにして
母が毎日ご飯食べて食べさせて食べさせることもゼロにして
こんなこと言われたんだと
それだけ覚えて いつか隙間を見て母を殺すと決めちゃうんです
これで正しい生き方ですかね
考えてみれば で この失敗はどんな人間もやってます
次の問題は皆様も同じなんです
過去を覚えているつもりでしょ？覚えていないんです
調理したものだけ覚えているんです
調理するときの調味 調味
何量？調味料っていうのは感情なんです
怒り 嫉妬 憎しみなどなどなんです
だからはっきり言えば
我々の記憶っていうのは猛毒に猛毒以外何でもないんです
そこで問題は なんで私たちはこんなすごい失敗するのかと
で ブッダの話を聞かなかったからとか
それは言い訳にならない
ブッダの話を聞いたっても
その時はもう間違いを起こして終わってるんだからね
生まれた時からやってるんだから
それだったら お腹の中にいる時はお釈迦様が説法しなくちゃいけない
これから君は生まれてくるんだから
そのデータすべてちゃんと覚えておいてくださいとか
調理するなよとかね ありえない話でしょうに
だから お釈迦様の話を聞かなかったからとかいうわけにはならない
人間ならこの大失敗 この致命的な失敗をするんです
この理由があるんです
これは自我なんですね
自分という存在なんです
どうも自分がいるんだという
何か実感が生まれてくるんです
誰にでもあるでしょ 自分がいるという実感
私という実感 これなんです
問題は 自我は幻覚ですが
みんなにあります ある程度で自我という錯覚に気づいている人々は
常識的に生きることにします
これ 俺の自我ですね ということは
子供でも親にわがまま言っちゃうと
ちょっと気づく そこまでわがまま言うべきかと気づいちゃうと
すぐ大人しくなっちゃうんです
そうすると お願いしますから
お母ちゃん なんとかなんと
すごく丁寧になっちゃうんです
自我に気づかないと 親に暴言吐くんです
なんでお前を産んだ親ではないかと
お金あげるのはあなたの義務ではないかとかね
義務ではないんだけどね
親が全然家から追い出したってもね
どうったことないんで
出て行けと 一人で生活できたらならばさようならなんですよ
動物たちそうやってるでしょうに
孫まで面倒見てやるぞとか
なんだこれ 変でしょ だからそうでもどうでもいいんですけど
自我に気づいてない場合は
あんなことんでもない言葉すら使うんですよ
あんた 私を産んだ親ではないかと
だからこの時助けてあげるのは当たり前のことではないかと
親も頭が悪いんだから落ち込むのはそうなんですけどとか
当然でじゃないんです
お前を産んだことは事実ですけどね
だから何をと 帰れ 言ってもいいんです
私はお前を産んだからといって
お前に私に指令しなさいと
誰だけ見たんですかと
だったら産んで育てた私が指令しますよと
だからその理性がないでしょ
親に なんで感情 親には子供に対してヘリクツな感情があるんです
だから頭が動かないんです
親にわがまま言うと 親が逆にそれ言い返せばいいでしょうに
だから私は何言っても言い返す母親に育てられたんです
母親といろいろ議論して勝ったことはちっちゃい時でしたけどもね
一度もないんです 次 親が言い返す
なんでそんなことやらなくちゃと
するとこちらにはもう何とも言えなくなっちゃうんです
だっていろいろなもの必要になるでしょうに
こういうふうに言われることもあるんですよ
あのね これがあるならば
お前にあげないという理由があるんですかと
お前これちょうだいちょうだいということは
もし家にあるならば 母親はとっくにあげてるでしょうに
だからバカわからないのかと
言っちゃって自分がバカになっちゃうんですね
もう親にあげられないものをいろいろおねだりしたっても
こちらが欲しい欲しいだけ考えているんですね
ああいうふうにリクエストでギャフンとやられちゃうと
こちらの頭が冴えてくるんです
あ なるほどと 子供だから母親に負けたという気がしませんだけど
でも確かに大人になってみたら
ものの見事に負けて負けて負けて負けてきたんです
現代人の場合は 親が負けて負けて負けて負けてくるんですね
なんか逆さまになっちゃったんです
だから私は昔生まれてよかったと思ってるんです
はい 度を超した幻覚に執着すると
様々なトラブルが起きます
自分に自我あるっていうことは
ものすごく度を越しちゃうんですね
度を越しちゃうっていうことは
自我があることすら忘れているんです
忘れたら その人々はみんな精神的に病気なんです
自分が自我張ってるんだよと
知った方が安全です だから仏教ではもともと自我を張ることを自体錯覚と言ってるんだけど
まあそこまで進まなくてもいいんです
俺はわがままですと はっきりと自覚がある人は問題ないんです
私はわがままですと だから問題は
自分がわがままで自我を張っている
もうもうどうにもならない性格であるということに気づいていない
この状態は精神病として現れます
私もこの精神病にかかっている人々とは話してみると
よくあることというのは
この人々が度を超した自我なんです
あまりにも もう私たちにも自我があるんだけど
でも社会でやられちゃうでしょ
だから我々の自我がくたくた攻撃受けて傷だらけなんです
だから自我張りたい時でも
ちょっと考え直すんです
なんか自分が偉そうにななきゃいけに行っても
向こうは批判する バカにする
それで 私の自我が傷ついちゃうんですね
そうやって常識な人間の自我が傷だらけなんですよ
それにすごくこの幻覚が傷だらけだから
あんまり問題は起こしません
時々あまりにも度を越しちゃって
人と会わせないんですね
会わせちゃうと攻撃を受けるんだから
だから人間関係から自分が離れるんです
離れるために言い訳するんです
みんな私のことを悪口言ってるんだと
そこで我々聞きます どうやって知ってる？あなたに知らなくて
私はよく知ってるんだと
あるお母さんが私に言ったことなんですけど
娘さんのことでね  3階
建物 3階かなんか上に行くんだけど
3階の窓から娘さんがドアを開けて
バス停に二人がいたんだと
お母さん お母さん あの二人がね
私の悪口言ってるんだと
そしたらお母さんがそこ聞こえないですよ
お母さんにわかりませんだからね
と言われたんです それから私にお母さん言うんですね
自分の娘はすごく能力あるんだよと
だから二人とも病気でしょ
なんで母親が病気になったかというと
ヘリックスの愛情 素直に自分の産んだ子はもう人間失格だと見てみれば
頭が壊れているんだと
それはお母さんのせいじゃないんです
自我の錯覚はお母さん作るんじゃないんです
お母さんには栄養をあげることはできます
お父さんにも お前こそ偉いや
かわいいやとかね 世界一やとかね
2 たす 2 はと計算しただけで
ああ すごい 将来は数学者になるぞ
オリンピックでメダル取るぞと
見た目で自我栄養をあげることはできますよ
しかし 自我が自分で作る錯覚なんですね
そこでああいう人々は度を越して自我があって
そこで人と喋ると自我が傷つくんだから喋れないことにする
引っ込もったりする あるいは統合
なんとか何とか病気ありますね
思症フレミア言うんですけどね
いろんな時々自分にはいろんな人の声は聞こえる
神の声は聞こえる 悪魔の言葉が聞こえるとかね
そうやってある自我ですよ
あれを肯定するために
他の人々を否定して捨てるためにこうやってやることで
完璧治療不可能な人間になるんです
精神的な病気になった人々を治療できないんです
というのは 自分自身が度を越した自我であるということは認めないんですね
それ認めない限りは治療は不可能なんです
言ったらかなり言われますよ
馬鹿にされます 私 喋る時でも結構馬鹿にしようと思うんです
みんなそう言ったのは違いますよとか言うんです
私とはそううまくいきませんだからね
私はもうすごく攻撃してね
帰ってください なぜならば
私はこの免許を取っているカウンセラーではありません
だからいちいち面倒見てあげる義理がないんです
話を聞く 聞かない さようなら
言う通りにやる やるんだったら助けてあげる
やらないんだったら はい
ちょうだい 帰ってちょうだいと
厳しいんですよ 私は 普通の人間には優しいんです
この傷だらけの自我を持ってる人にとっては
丁寧にその人々は認めますからね
それ自我だと認めたら直せ
直せます とにかくこの自我の錯覚で精神病までかかっちゃうんです
この錯覚が事実を勝手に変えて合成してねつ造して
その上現実だと講じます
ちょっと難しいポイントなんですけど
私たちには自我という錯覚がある
自我の錯覚があると 怒り
嫉妬 憎しみなどなどの感情がいっぱい現れる
私が怒った 私が腹が立った
私が落ち込んだとかね
いう場合は自我なんです
自我がなければ落ち込めないでしょ？自我がなければ怒らないでしょ
自我がなければ嫉妬が出てこないでしょ
そういうことで自我がある
感情がある 自我が生産する感情がある
それでデータを熱想像する
いわゆる料理する 料理して知識だと思う
自分知っていることは正しいと公示する羽目になるんです
面白いでしょ 人間の心理は
はい 次 情報の熱想像について考えましょう
面白くないんで このチャプターは
眼耳鼻舌身意 意という情報を感じる
六根に外の世界の情報を感じる窓口が 6つあります
で これはブッダの分析で仕方がないんです
これは事実です 皆様の自我でいくら否定したってもどうしようもないんです
情報を知るための窓口 6つあります
眼耳鼻舌身意と言うんですね
そこに触れる情報は色声
何と言ったら色声香味触法というグループ 6つに分けています
中身は説明できませんだから
まあ別な勉強会でもやらないと
触れますが ん？なんか変になっちゃった
誰一人もその事実に気づかないんです
気づかないでしょ 目から情報が入って認識が生まれていくという流れが気づかないんです
ああ 私は見ているんだとかね
もう捏造しているんです
美しい風景が見える 快い音楽が聞こえる
食べるものが美味しいなどなどを認識しているんです
私たちは認識している
そういうものです なんて美しい風景ですか
なんで心地よい音楽ですか？とかね
このアホ そんなことはないんですけどね
この熱想像した世界が知識だと思っているんです
感情という主観で調理してから知る世界が現れますが
一度たりともあるがままの事実を知ることはしない
熱想像したものは事実であるとするんですね
例えば見えるでしょ？見えることはしないんです
見ることしないんです
あのデータを調理するんです
なんて美しいことですか
とかね あれ欲で あるいはつまらないとか
気持ち悪いとかね 醜いとかね
処理するんです それであの姿は醜い
確かです 終わり どんなデータが降るのか知らないんです
過去とはこの熱装したデータなんですね
だから我々思っている過去っていうのは熱装したデータなんです
熱装したデータ いわゆるデータを熱装した結果なんです
逆に書いた方が良かったと思います
あったことのない過去だから
私たちにある過去が本当はあったこともないんです
過去を過去と思ってるでしょ？そのあったことすらないんです
過去だと思い出すものは
一つも起きた事実ではないんです
個人が作るストーリーです
個人が自分のストーリーを持っているから
他人のストーリーを気にしない
認めない 異常だと思う
だから自分が感情でストーリーを作る
このストーリーが自分の過去だと思っちゃう
思っちゃうんですね だからストーリーだから
どんなストーリーも作れるんですよ
でもそれほど能力ないんです
私は自分の過去のデータを見てすごい楽しいんですよ
一つのストーリーを作る
いい これじゃない 別なストーリーを作ろうと
これも別 いくらでも作れます
だから過去のデータも適当に選ぶんだからね
適当に選んでストーリー作っちゃえばいいんです
私のすごい昔 ちょっと前
何年か前 面白い出来事があって
私の弟子が子供が一人いるんだけど
で もう小さい時ね 学校に入れてあるんですよ
だからもう休みは時々
まあ今お寺に戻っていると思いますけど
今休みだからね でないと学校でそこで作ってるんです
まあガキたちだからいろいろやっちゃうでしょうに
だからお坊さんの学校だから
もう恐ろしく厳しいんですね
だから私は学校って言わないんです
十歳の刑務所やと だからお坊さんの学校っていうのは
立派な人間を作る場所じゃなくて
人間の能力を粉々に破壊する場所やと
すごい反対ですけど 仕方がないんですね
そこで何か出来事あって
このこいつは罰を受ける羽目になっちゃったんですね
パニッシュメントになったんですね
まだ行ったことはないんだけど
どうったことない それで私はこの情報が他の人から聞いたんですね
聞いた時も 言った人も
まあもう子供だから可愛いでしょうという感じで言ってくれるんですよ
まあもうやんちゃでいたずらやってるんだよという感じで
私も話を聞いてニコッと笑っただけで
子供がやったことに対しては全く何も思ってないんですね
でもパニッシュメントを受けたんだから
これでもってこいつをからかってやるとと思ったんです
からかってやるためにはストーリーを作らなくちゃいけないんですね
あのちょこっとしたデータで
私は組み立てたで ストーリーは組み立てて
あのね 君はとかね こんなことやって
こんなことやってとかね
というストーリー言っちゃうと
子供がいくらなんでもと気持ちになっちゃったんです
だから私は言ってることはストーリーで嘘知ってるんです
ただ まあ自分が育ててる子供だから
まあこいつは可愛いんですよ
それは全然問題ないし
学校でやったことには私は微塵もなんでこんなことやるのかということは絶対言わない
もっとやれという気持ちなんです
その方が元気やと それでストーリーがあまりにも組み立てたんだから
子供はびっくりしちゃって
普段喋らないんです 私と
いきなり前に出て あのね
私にそうではありません
実数はこういうことあって
こういうことあって こういうことあって
先生がものすごく誤解しちゃって
私にパニッシュメントしたんだけど
実は私は何こともやってないんだと
それで私はああそう終わった
私のストーリーはもう却下されちゃったんです
でも逆にその子は自分の弁解したことがね
しっかりしているなと
見込みがある子やと思ったんです
あまりも社会がひどく誤解して言うならば
前に出てきて弁解してやるという
そこはすごいいい性格でね
だからこのストーリーっていうのは
そうやっていくらでも作られる
だから私は自分の子供に対して作ったストーリーがまるっきり嘘でしてるんです
嘘ですけど データを入れてるんです
だから私たちはこの過去のデータ
一つ 二つ 三つ選んで ありえないストーリーを作るんですね
そこでストーリーで生きているんです
だから 自分が作ったストーリーは
隣の人を作るストーリーと違うでしょ
だからもう人のことを認めなくなっちゃうんです
人を批判したくなっちゃうんです
人のストーリーを却下したくなっちゃうんですね
だからストーリーを作ったことで
自分が一人ぼっちになっちゃうんです
主観的なストーリーの導きで生きようとします
そこで 自分の生きるためのマニュアルは何なのかというと
自分が作ったストーリーなんです
これ嘘なんです 事実じゃないんです
だから よくもここまで嘘のマニュアルで生きていることが面白いでしょう
事実 現実 事実とマッチしないので失敗します
だから人類の生き方は誰であろうとも失敗なんです
成功者は一人もいません
あのトランプさんの TWITTER の言葉と同じなんです
言っちゃったら何か間違いなんです
しかし アメリカの大統領なんです
言葉一つ真面目に書けないんです
それの結果 不幸に陥ります
だから人類は幸福を目指している
しかし 人類はたどり着かない
目的の幸福なんです だって完全間違いのマニュアルを参考していますからね
だから完全なマニュアルじゃなくて
完全間違いのマニュアル
はい そういうことで 知的障害というテーマで考えてみましょうか
生命は人間が知的障害者なんです
私が感じた音を気に入りました
心地よい音でした それを気持ち悪い
うるさい 騒音として認めることも
認識を変えることも不可能です
できません 例えばどなたかこちらでチェロで何かベートーヴェンの何かちょっとしたパートをやる
はぁ 気持ちいいでしょ？うるさいなと思える？こんな騒音
これ殺虫音でしょ 思える？思えない
すごいハンディがあるんです
だから私が言いたいポイントは
耳に音が触れる その音をどのようにも判断できる
はぁ 心地よい音楽だとも判断できる
ただの音でしょうとも判断できる
せっかく本読んでるんだからうるさいと判断もできる
その自由ありますか？食べたものが美味しかったんです
まずかった 気持ち悪かった
味がお粗末でしたなどの認識は不可能です
私はあまり食べるものの名前を知らないんだから
うなぎにしますけどもね
だから私は皆様 毎日うなぎ食ってる人みたいとね
まあ正しく認識してください
構いませんだけど あまり名前知らないんです
で うなぎ弁当を食べていて
ああ なんで美味しいですか？と思っちゃうでしょ
私はいえ これまずいでしょうと
これ不可能なんです 私は一回うなぎいただいたかどうか分かりませんだけど
食べていろいろ判断しながら食べたんです
日本人が感情でストーリーで
うなぎって豪華な食べ物やというストーリーがあるんですね
だから品物を食ってないんです
うなぎってまずい魚なんですよ
ヌルヌルしちゃって あれ
いろんなの あれ 漬物なんてまた何かでかけなきゃまずいんです
何かひどい濃い液体かけるでしょ
あの液体の味なんです
あの それで この日本の文化的な価値観で考えたら
あ なかなか珍しいごちそうの食べ物やと言って
そこで食べて味を感じて
それからこの店の人々は自分の秘伝のタレ持ってますから
はい このタレと合わせたの味は何なのかと
で それ判断して 次にこれで本当に美味しいんですかと
噛んでみたらまずかったんですね
やっぱり それから じゃあご飯の味と別々どうですか？だからいろんなバリエーションできるんですよ
ちょっと訓練しておけば
こんなロボットになる必要ないんです
うなぎは美味しいに決まってるとかね
焼肉は美味しいに決まってるとかね
そうじゃないんです 美味しく感じる場合も
まずく感じる場合もあります
その自由は私たちにないんです
皆さまにうなぎ弁当配ったら
あ うなぎだ すごいやと言う
必ず言うんです すべての情報に対する認識を自分自身で変えることはできません
すごいハンディでしょ
すごいハンディです さあ
こちら花がありまして
これを見てどんな判断するのかというと
皆様いろいろ言うかもしれませんだけど
この花を見る範囲でいる方々にとっては
判決は前もって下しているんです
この先に判断してからデータ調べるんです
だから判決は先 証言は後という生き方です
判決が先だったら 後の証言何の関係もないでしょうに
この花はまあそれなりに綺麗ですよと思う人もいるし
ちょっと小さすぎじゃない？と思う人もいるし
このビニール外した方がよかったのにとかね
思う人いるでしょうに
私が思うことですかね
私はいろいろ思うんだからね
しかし 私たちはやっぱり一応固定した
前もって定めた判断があって
それからデータを受け取ろうとするんだから
データを崩してないんです
したがって 私の知る世界
そのまま事実です で これちょっとわかりにくい文章なんです
例えばこの 例えばうなぎご飯はごちそうだと決まってる人にとっては
うなぎはごちそうです
サンマのサンマのかぶ焼きもあったっけ
この間店に行ったらなんかそういう名前見たんだけどね
サンマのかぶ焼き なんだあれは
うなぎのかぶ焼き これ気づいたのはなんかかぶ焼きとあって
値段見たらすごい安い値段とまた見たらすごい高い
ああ なるほど うなぎのかぶ焼きでサンマのかぶ焼きもあるんだと
どちらでも食べませんとかありましたけど
で まあこれは皆様の食事ですから
だからうなぎのかぶ焼きだったら美味しいに決まってる
サンマのかぶ焼きはどうですかね
まあ他なければ美味しいですね
他買えることなければという世界でしょうね
だってサンマって安いんだから
そういうわけで 私が知る世界があるんです
私が知る世界 私に変えることは不可能です
私が聞いた音が私にとって心地よい音楽であったならば
私にそれ変えられません
私はそれが事実とするんです
何か食べる 舐めてみる
美味しく感じる そうすると私がその品物が美味しいですと
これは美味しい品物ですと決める
例えばアメを舐めているでしょうに
アメ舐めたら美味しいですと決めちゃうでしょうに
だからそれ研究しないんですよ
私は体に砂糖が必要であって
喉も口もなんか乾いちゃってる状態で
アメちょっと子供たちからもらって舐めたことあって
美味しかった時もある
それからそういう気持ちがない時も取って舐めてみた
そうするとなんだめんどくさいと
早く飲み込もうと 舐めることはバイパスしちゃったんです
というわけで 私には固定した判断がないんです
人間にはいつでも固定された判断があるんです
これ変えられない わかりやすければ
うなぎ弁当まずいと判断してくださいと頼んでも無理でしょ
モーツァルトはもううるさいんだと
イライラするんだと判断してみて
できる？できないでしょ
なんか日本ね 年一年一回モーツァルトを聴く時期がある
今でしたっけね 第九を聴いたりとかね
これ毎年やってますね
どれほどロボットかというと
で この心の理由ないんです
モーツァルトの何か曲を聴くと決まってる反応が起こる
これ そのその人に決められた反応なんですね
コンサートに行ったからといって
みんな同じ感動するわけじゃないんです
時々 旦那さんと奥さんがコンサートに行く
やっぱ旦那さんがゴルフに行きたかったんだけど
こいつはうるさいんだからね
もう一年前にチケットを用意してあったんだから
じゃあ一緒に行こうと
一緒に行って座ってあげるんだけど
ゴルフやればよかったのにとかいう気持ちでいるんですね
奥さんがね ね お面白いでしょ？面白いでしょう？と言うと
うるさいんだけど そうですね
素晴らしいですねとかね
と言ったりもする だからそれぞれ人が
それぞれの決まった判断する
だから私が知る世界はそれでしょう
これで事実です 私にとっては
モーツァルトは素晴らしいと思う人にとっては
私はうるさいと言っちゃうと
その人はあなた間違っていると言うんですね
そういうわけで 私が知る世界はそのまま事実になっているんです
目に色というエネルギー
流れが触れて感覚の流れが生じます
では 仏教的に説明します
目に色と仏教で名前ラベルを貼ってますけど
色というエネルギーの流れがずっと触れてるんです
このエネルギーの流れが触れると
感覚の流れが目の中で起きるんです
固定していないんです
何か見えるわけじゃないんです
エネルギーがずっと流れてるんです
そうすると目の中でずっと感覚の流れが起こるんです
そちらに美しい風景も感動する花もありませんよ
目を開けてると 生で色というんですけど
何かエネルギーが触れてるんです
すーっと触れてるんです
すーっと触れてる時は
すーっと感覚が起きて
起きて 起きて 起きて 起きて
消えて 起きて 消えて 起きて消えていくんです
で 激しい流れ 2つなんです
皆様の知識世界では 目に見えるということは光だと思ってるでしょ
実は光は見えないのに
でも学校に行ったら人に光が見えると言うんですね
で 光は見えませんよ まあそれはいいんですけど
置いておいて とにかく目に何かのエネルギーが触れることだけ確かなんです
そこで私がなんて美しい風景でしょうかと
窓から山の方を見てね
あるいは富士山見えるんだったら
富士山の方を見て なんて美しい風景でしょうかと
美しい風景見えてるんです
本当はないんですけど
こちらただ激しい流れが二つあるだけなんです
認識する人は瞬間にデータを熱想したので
見たのは美しい風景であることは決まっているんですね
今もそれなりのバックグラウンドに画像を入れましたけどね
そう 画像ないんですよ
あまり私が決まった色では映してないんです
で まあそれは仕方がないんですが
ちょっと暗いんだけどね
もうちょっとコントラストを作ったんだけど
出てこない それは私のせいじゃなくて
機械のせいですね そこで皆様にここからエネルギーがスーッと触れていると感じますかね
感じないでしょう どうしても文字は忘れたいんだから
文字を忘れてこの背景の画像を見てください
そうするとこちらに まあ美しいかどうかは皆様の個人的な判断だから
一応画像は見えるんですね
ということは ナノ秒の速さで争いが起きているんです
そこで我々は哲学者になります
我は知る故に私こそが正しいと
ただ 皆様の間で大喧嘩させることは至って簡単
一人一人この背景画像について意見を書いてくださいと
そこで二人 二人こちらに上がってもらって
自分の意見を弁解しなさいと
大喧嘩になるでしょう
やりましょうか みんなにアンケートを
バックグラウンドの画像
背景が 表には文字が入れてますからね
それについて自分の意見
判断 感想 それ二人 三人
じゃあ弁解してくださいと
言うと喧嘩になる なんで喧嘩に気持ち悪くなる？あるいは怯えてしまって
もしかするとあなた言ってるあなたの感想の方が正しいかもとかね
惨めになったりする それは言っても嘘ですけどね
へっちゃらで嘘を言う
例えば凶暴で口達者な人がガチャガチャガチャガチャガチャガチャ言っちゃうと
やっぱり考えてみれば
あなたの意見 自分の感想は別なんですけど
そういうふうに嘘を言う羽目になる
とにかく 私は知る故に私こそが正しいという哲学者になるんです
そういう生き方表れます
これは省略すると知的障害なんです
みんなにあるんです おそらく
お釈迦様はそういう批判的な単語を使いません
お釈迦様はもう悟っているんだから
これ無明というんです
私はわざと批判的な単語を選んだ
感情の判断は過去です
現実的な過去と思っているのは
事実ではなく 主観で感情で捏造した経験と判断の塊です
我々は過去と思っているのは過去ではないんです
感情で判断したものなんです
だから大体ちょっと理解してほしい
我々は過去だと思っているのは
感情でした判断であって
本物の過去ではありません
人が過去を参考すること
過去に惹かれること 過去を生かすことなどは
自分が掘った苦しみの落とし穴に自分自身で落ちることです
過去を参考するでしょ
過去の経験を生かしているでしょ
あれは嘘の過去なんです
自分で苦しむの穴を掘って
自分で落ちる 私はこの例えには自慢します
みんな自分が掘った穴に落ちているんです
もう上がらないんです
自分がかなり立派に作ったんだから
上上がらないように 上がれないように
あらゆる苦しいことを怪我すること
いろんなものを作っちゃって
居心地悪くように だけど
落ちたい人をいじめたいでしょ
それで落とし穴を作ったんだけど
自分が落ちちゃったから
そうやって私たちは自分好みの過去を作っちゃうんです
それからその過去の穴に落ちちゃうんです
生きることは苦であるとは
知的障害で捏造した幻覚の世界を作っているからなんです
だからお釈迦様は生きることは苦であると教えたでしょ
これちょっとあるんです
ポイントは 生命は知的障害者なんです
捏造した幻覚の穴に落ちているんです
それだけ そういうわけでお釈迦様の言葉は破れ難い過去という檻ですね
これ破れないんですね
過去ってすごい難しい
仏教ではブッダの有名な言葉でアティータンナーンワーゲメイヤ
過去を追ってはならないと
そこで言っているのは
事実参考にしてはならないではないんです
しかし 実行は難しい それで事実まで忘れて
病気 病弱状態になりなさいと言っているのではないが
ないかと拒絶反応を起こします
過去を追うなよと言ったら
こういうふうに拒絶反応を起こすんです
全部病気隠していいんですかねとか
過去って大事でしょうにと
とお釈迦様に 拒絶反応を起こしちゃうんです
落とし穴からは立ち上がりた上がりたくないんですね
感情で捏造した嘘の過去
幻覚の過去を捨てなさいという意味です
お釈迦様が言うのは 嘘の過去を捨てなさいよ
幻覚の過去を捨てなさいよ
あなたの落とし穴に入っているんだよ
家に帰る道を忘れなさいと言ってないんです
それも過去の知識でしょ
講演が終わったら家に帰る
過去のデータ参考していますよ
だから我々は毎日過去を参考しているんですよ
家に帰る場合は 電車で帰る場合は
じゃあ中野駅まで行かなくちゃとか
自分がどんな線を選ぶのかとかね
急行に乗るのか 普通の各停に乗るのか
すべて過去のデータでしょ
それで問題起こる？起こりませんよ
あれは捏造していないんです
この目で電車選ぶんじゃないでしょ
あれが新幹線好きだから
じゃあ家に帰るために新幹線に乗るぞ
やりませんね 現実的に
電車を選ぶんです 現実的にバスを選ぶんです
だから 事実である過去は常に役に立っています
今 私は日本語を喋っているでしょ
それって能力過去でしょ
忘れてないんです 役に立ってます
だから その差を理解してください
お釈迦様は過去を追うなかれというのは
この感情で作った幻覚の嘘の過去なんです
あの仏典読んでみると
皆様知ってるでしょ？お釈迦様は過去生でこうであった
ああであったとか教えてるでしょ
人の過去まで喋ってるでしょうに
あれは過去を追うことじゃないんです
事実を並べるだけなんです
事実を並べるだけ それがすごい能力ですよ
はい もう時間なくなっちゃったんだから飛ばしましょう
破れ難い過去という折
続けていきます 私はまるまると覚えているすべての幻覚の過去を捨てるべきです
覚えておいてください
自分の記憶たくさんありますね
この記憶の中で 私はまるまる
私はまるまるという記憶あるでしょ
あれはすべて嘘です あれは嘘です
家に帰りたければ 中野駅で何々中央線に乗らなくちゃいけないっていうのは事実です
だから この嘘過去にいつでも私という主語が入ってくるんです
私はあの人のこと好きです
嘘ですね それは嘘です
これも過去のデータなんです
今 その人はここにいません
だから今いても 私は君のこと好きですと言ったら
それは嘘なんです なぜならば
いろいろデータが目に触れた
触れたデータを自分の感情で調理した
調理した結果 この人に言うんです
この人はうるさい 迷惑だと反応する
そうするとこちらは落ち込みます
私はあなたのこと好きですと
私は大嫌いですと言われたら大変でしょう
だから私は入っちゃう
入った過去はすべて嘘
理解してください バラク・オバマさんはアメリカ合衆国の 44番目の 44番目でしたっけね
大統領でした そちら私が入ってる？入ってないね
それは事実です これ過去で本物の過去です
私の主観に関係ありません
事実的な過去が役に立ちます
覚えた方がいい バラクはどうでもいいんだけど
我々は覚えた方が良い
過去はいくらでもあります
それは事実のみ 主語主語が私だったらすべて嘘です
これはすごい大事な難しいポイントです
覚えておいてください
主語が私で積み重ねた過去が幻覚です
単純に得た主語が第三人称で得たデータは事実です
しかし 人のすべての経験は私という器に入れているので
捨てることができなくなっています
面白いことには 学校で学んだ数学まで私に入れちゃうんです
バカじゃないかなと もっと頭をすごく勉強できますよ
数学の私は今の年代でもできます
もし一から教えてくれるならば
私は見事に勉強してみせますよ
他の人より 100倍のスピードで
しかし 正しく教える順番で教える先生が必要です
私に本を開けて勉強したってわからないんです
だから私というあれに入れなきゃ
すごい能力なんです だから過去を捨てなさいというのは
この私という器 これは存在しない器です
この器自体が猛毒なんです
だから入れたデータも全部猛毒になっているんです
それを参考にして生きているんですね
精神の病に 丁寧に治療を施さなくてはいけない
だから我々はみんな生命は知的障害で
どうも眼耳鼻舌身のデータを捏造しちゃう
捏造して私で錯覚を作って
その錯覚にデータを適当に入れる
入れて そこを参考にして生きているということは
完全に間違った生き方しています
だからこの重病なんですね
そういうわけで 丁寧に治療しなくちゃいけないんです
ちょっと 10分程度休憩いたします
この間違った過去に引っ張られて
間違った過去 存在しない過去に導かれて生きるということは
我々は気づいていないし
これは精神的な問題ということにしまった
ですから 人が病気になったら丁寧に治療しなくちゃいけないんですね
これから治療法 で いきなり言いますから
なんかどう理解すればいいんですかね
到着するゴールはない
この生きるということで
最終的に到着するゴールっていうのは存在しないんです
生きるとは行為の流れです
目的はありません はい
これ実践します はい まずでは立ちましょう
ということで 今日は実践できませんだからポイントだけ説明します
瞬時に頭の中に立って終わった姿の目的が現れます
では立ちましょう 言ったら
すぐ立った姿が頭に入っちゃうんです
それがゴールになるんです
目的になるんです これは将来の妄想ですね
すぐ将来を妄想しちゃったんです
誰よりも早く妄想してからね
誰よりも早くゴールに達しようと必死になるんです
焦るんです ストレスを感じるんです
過去で勝ったことも 負けたことも
頭に割り込んできます
これが人生で これはい
立ちましょうと言った途端に
そのすべて入るんです
これ 小さなサンプルで
他でも番組作りましょうかと
あるいは番組作ってちょうだいと言った途端
このプログラムが現れるのです
プロセスを無視して 手抜きでいい加減で
結果さえ良ければという感じで出すんです
そこなんでね はい 出しましょうと言った途端
この最後に書いた文章の通りに足すんです
みんな プロセスはどうでもいいんです
立てばいいでしょうと
これも他の人より先に立てばいいでしょうと
あるいは逆にみんな足すならば俺も足しますという
そうなるんですね はい
次 仏教的な場合 では立ちましょう
足すとはメモだけの概念です
そこではい 私は言います
では立ちましょう 言った途端
あの言葉はちょっとしたメモだけ存在しない
メモに足すということを書いただけです
今いる状況から次の行為をする
だからブッダ 仏道の人だったら立ちましょうと言った途端
あるいはちょっとメモを置いておく
使いません 今の状況を調べる
今座ってますね はい 次どうするのかと
次どうするのかと 次の行為をする
足すということも忘れちゃったんです
もう忘れてたんだからメモにしちゃったんです
忘れていいんです メモはあるんだから
その結果から現れる次の行為をする
例えば こうやって座ってますね
私ははい では立ちましょうと言ったら
手を結んでいるんだから
次手を外す それで足が弱いんだから
じゃあ手で支える それから腰を上げる
それからもっと上げる
で 膝をまっすぐにする
で 整えるとかね いろいろ仕事が現れてくるんです
このように瞬間瞬間に現れる行為をします
仏道の人なら 一般の人は周りを見て
あ あいつも立って じゃあ私も立たなくちゃとかいうすごい間違ったことをするんです
はい 立ちましたと言った途端
じゃあ誰より先に立ってみますと
自我張るんですね 仏教はそうじゃないんです
目的ありません 立ちますと言ったっても
あれはただのメモの言葉だけです
今どうするの？今どうするの？今どうするの？次どうするの？次どうするの？次どうするの？するののプロセスなんです
そこで困らなくていい
例えば座っている人が
例えば履物を脱いでいたとしましょう
その人は出さなくちゃあかんだから
じゃあまず履物をまた足につけますとかね
次これやります 次これやります
次これやります 立つとは行為の連続の最後の瞬間だけです
たった一コマの行為なんです
立ってからは次の行為が現れてくるんですよ
立って終わったわけじゃないんです
立って次の行為が現れる
次の行為が現れる 例えば 5 分間立ってくださいと言ったら
5 分間も瞬間瞬間立つっていう姿を保たせなくちゃいけないでしょ
だから立つ完了じゃないんです
はい  5 分間は立てるでしょ
あなたでも でも立ったことを完了したら楽ちんでしょうに
完了しないんです 立っても 5 分間
あらゆる工夫をしながら立ち続けるという行為をしなくちゃいけないんです
その間で私はチェックすると
手は動かしているわ 首があちらこちら見ているわ
いろんなことをやっていますね
だからそれ全部禁止させるんです
すべて禁止させて 手を結んでまっすぐ立ってくださいと
背筋を伸ばして はい それから 5 分かけてくださいと
こういう風に こう柱のように立っても大変です
次から次 次から次 次から次へと足す足す足す足すことをやらなくちゃいけないんです
だから終了がないんです
完成がないんです ゴールがないんです
はいはい  5 分終わりましたと言ったら
私はでは座ってくださいと
座るとはただのメモ それから次の次の次の次の行為をしなくちゃいけないんです
終わりがないのです 目的ゴールは存在しないんです
はい これやる場合は 私はこの過去から解放するのを教えているんです
ただ足す訓練で いろいろ訓練がありますね
思考を停止しなくちゃいけないんです
思考はほとんど自分が作った過去物語ですね
あれやめたいでしょ あれ間違いでしょ
存在しないでしょ あったことはないでしょ
そんな過去は だから思考を止めなくちゃいけないんですね
その幻覚に支配されると
足す流れが失敗します
例えば妄想しながら立っちゃうと完璧失敗です
もう気持ち悪いほど失敗です
それは人々にやらせているんだから
もう気持ち悪くて気持ち悪くて瞑想会やめたくなるぐらい
だから日本の特色がありまして
絶対誘導にやらないというね
それかかってくるんだから
民族性 ですから 瞬間瞬間の行為を実況することで妄想の障害を乗り越えられます
だからはい 手を外す 腰をちょっと上げる
もうちょっと上げる もうちょっと上げるとかね
まあちょっとちょっと入りません
上げる 上げる 上げる 上げると動詞で実況するんです
なぜならば あるのは行為なんです
行為は言語では動詞で使うしかないんです
立つという名詞がありません
立つという瞬間もない
瞬間立ったら次の瞬間立たなくちゃいけない
次の瞬間立たなくちゃいけない
この瞬間というのは 人の個人能力によって幅が大きくなったり
狭くなったりする できるだけ狭くしてほしいんです
それは訓練を繰り返さなくちゃいけないんです
だから瞬間やること 実況しましょう
手を出す場合も手を外します
そうすると両手に意識がいっちゃうんだから面倒くさい
はい 左手下げる下げる下げる下げる下げる
置く 右手下げる下げる下げる下げる
置く はい 腰を上げる上げる上げるとかね
そうやって一個ずつ実況しながら
行為一個一個一個やってみるんです
妄想の石灯籠に引っかかると
精神的な病が治りません
これ治療ですよ 我々のこの運命的な
天命的な この知的障害
これを治したいんです
だから妄想だけはしてはいけません
妄想とは過去です だから
すごい真剣に薬飲むような感じで
注射するような感じで
零点何ミリかと薬の精密に決めるでしょう
そんな感じで真剣に実況しなくちゃいけないんです
病の原因は一般人に理解できないが
病の症状である妄想から現れる苦しみは知っているんです
だから 私はなんで知的障害ですか？と
私知りません 仏教はあれ自我だよと言ったんだけど
本人は知らない 正直になってください
自我が幻覚であるということは
皆様知らない 皆様にとって自我っていうのはね
本物です 私がいるということは本物です
だからそれは素直で 私にとっては私がいることは本物でした
しかし この幻覚から現れる症状がわかります
例えば 私の体の中にがんが発生する
私は素人だから 細胞組織の中でがんがあることは知らない
知らないんだけど 食欲はないわ
体がだるいわ いろんなところ痛くなってくるわ
もう元気じゃないわ やる気がない
いろいろ症状あるでしょ
調子が悪いわ 食べても痩せてしまうわ
それで私は症状だけお医者さんに言う
それお医さんは血液検査と MRI なんとかにして
あなたのこういうところでこれぐらいのがんがありますよという
それは専門家が言うんです
それで私は先生 そんなことどうでもいいんだから
このだるいことに何とかしてくださいと
食べても体重が減ることに何とか
医者は何もしてあげません
医者はこれからがん治療しますと
がんに治療して 狙い撃ちでがんを亡くしたら健康ですね
そうやって我々は自我というがんにかかってますけど
知らない そんなのは これはお釈迦様が専門医者だから
お釈迦様は教えてくれる
お釈迦様は私が友達と喧嘩する
夫婦喧嘩する お釈迦様はそれを直す方法をあまり教えてあげません
教えてありますけど じゃあではあなたの病気に治療しましょう
そこで自我の...がんが治ったら
夫婦は喧嘩しないことになってるんです
友達と喧嘩しないことになってるんです
だから我々を訴えているのは症状なんです
世界は平和じゃないわ
家族は頑張っても豊かにならないわ
会社ではちゃめちゃ苦労したっても褒めてくれないわとかね
一生年取るまで家族に尽くしたんだけど
家族の連中は全く感謝の気持ちは持ってないわとかね
クリスマスになってるのに
誰も私にプレゼントを持ってこないわとかね
私に持ってこないでください
気持ち悪い で 皆様にとってはクリスマス大事なものするでしょうに
そういうふうに我々は症状だけ訴えている
自分の子供がクリスマスプレゼントを持ってこないのは
自分 子供の自我なんです
自分のことしか考えていないんです
子供がプレゼントを持ってきた方が嬉しいなと思っている母親は
母親の自我なんです だから我々は症状は知っている
原因は知らない これで治療は原因に治療します
過去だけではなく 未来の妄想もやめる
止める 今日のテーマは過去ですけど
未来も同じなんですね
ものを動かす 手を上げる下げるなどの行為を妄想停止して行ってみてください
例えば これは実際やると面白いんですよ
はい 手を挙げてくださいと私は言います
言った途端 頭にあの目的のイメージが現れるでしょ
これアウト 手を挙げるということはメモにしちゃう
メモにして 瞬間瞬間上げる
上げる 上げる 上げる 上げる
それだけやる 上げる 上げる
上げる あ 止める もう上げながらなくなっちゃったんですね
そこで止める だから手を挙げてくださいたっても無数の行為でしょ
そこで上げたままでいることでも行為なんですね
今止めてる状態だから
止めている 止めている
それから下げてくださいったら
下げる 下げる 下げる 下げる
下げる 下げると終わるまでやればいいんです
止めるところまで だから手を挙げたということはないでしょ
瞬間瞬間何か動き 動きがあって
それ動きが止まって 別な動きが現れて
それから次 瞬間瞬間別な動きがあって
その動きが止まって 別な動きが始まるんです
そういうわけで 自我の錯覚をなくすために手を上げたり下げたりすることはできます
それから私の瞑想会で教えますから
ものを動かす 至って簡単
例えばこういう風なものがありますね
これはこういう風にちゃんと置いておく
それから手はどのように置いたかと覚えておく
それから行為 瞬間瞬間行為をする
実況中継で 上げる 上げる
上げる 上げる 上げる 上げる
運ぶ 運ぶ 運ぶ 運ぶ 運ぶ
下ろす 下ろす 下ろす 下ろす
下ろす 取る 取る 取る 取る
上げる 上げる 上げる 上げる
運ぶ 運ぶ 運ぶ 運ぶ 下ろす
下ろす 下ろす 下ろす 下ろす
下ろす 置く 置く 置く 離す
離す 離す 上げる 上げる
上げる 上げる 戻す 戻す
戻す 戻す 戻す 戻す 置く
置く 置く で 手は元に戻しちゃうんです
それだけです それから後半やります
手を外す 外す 外す 伸ばす
伸ばす 伸ばす 上げる 上げる
上げる 伸ばす 伸ばす 伸ばす
伸ばす 下ろす 下ろす 下ろす
下ろす 取る 取る 取る 取る
上げる 上げる 上げる 上げる
運ぶ 運ぶ 運ぶ 運ぶ 下ろす
下ろす 下ろす 下ろす 置く
置く 置く 置く 置く 離す
離す 離す 上げる 上げる
上げる 戻す 戻す 戻す 下ろす
下ろす それがスローで
一個一個一個の行為をチェックしながらやるんです
極端にシンプルです それから我々は智慧を目指しているんです
智慧は何ですか？ゴールはありません
ストップはありません
一つ終わると次の行為が現れるんです
それが人生です  全ての行為にゴールが存在しないという事実を発見でき
心が変わるまで行ってみるんです
だから何やってもゴールがないんですよ
例えば料理しますといったら
料理がゴールでしょ？じゃないんです
出来上がったら食卓に運ぶ仕事
我々とそれから食べる仕事
我々とそれから後片付けの仕事
我々とそれから食べていても
別な仕事に行くという終わりがないんです
そこをしっかり理解するまで
こういう訓練しなくちゃいけないんです
この訓練が治療ですよ
自分の意欲 いわゆる意志
外の状況の条件で 次行うべき行為が自ら現れます
悩む必要は一切ないんです
例えば講演が終わったら
私は帰らなくちゃいけないんですね
それで私の意志なんですね
こちらでいると この管理の方々に殴られて追い出される可能性あります
だから自分の肉体では帰らなくてはと意志が生じた
でもそれは遠い目的でしょ
じゃない 回す 進む で 左足
右足進む 階段があります
降りる そういう感じで
次の行為 次の行為 次の行為が現れるんです
階段のところでは 私の足がちょっと弱いんだから
階段はどんどんとは下りませんね
で 手を伸ばす 手すりを取る
で 降りるということになるんです
だからなんで困るんですか？人々は
行為は自動的に現れてるんです
自分の意欲も一つの原因だけ
ただ 私はこういうものを動かす場合は
ちゃんと元に戻してくださいと言うんです
完璧に元に戻してくださいと
そこでこれ運んで 手を元に戻して
また運んで こう置けばいいんです
それはダメです 前にあった通りに置くんです
なぜですか？と 行為の自分の意志もかかっているんです
自分のインテンション
パーリ語でチェータナーと言うんですね
もかかっているんです
だから私の意志によって落とすこともできるし
どうでもいいんだからと置くこともできるし
いえ 元にあった通りにしましょうと言って
こういう風に元にあった通りに置くこともできるんですね
だから物を動かして修行してみてください
その場合は手は元に戻す
品物もちゃんと元に戻す
そうすると 自分の意志もすごい原義になっている
しかし ご飯炊きましょうと言っちゃうと
自分の意志では米を研いで
洗って適量な水を入れてスイッチを押すだけ
それから自分の意志は関係ないね
しかしただのご飯じゃなくて
炊き込みご飯の方がいいんじゃない？とかね
何か野菜とか何か米と一緒に入れた方がいいんじゃないかと言ったら
これ自分の意志 そうすると
米もきれいに洗って 適量な水を入れて
野菜を入れるならば 野菜にも水分がありますから
そこもちょっと計算して水分を微妙に減らしちゃって
で 味も入れるならば それなりにコンソメとかなんとかも入れて
そこまで自分の意志 それから閉めてスイッチを押したら自分には関係ない
そういうことで結果が現れるんであって
自分がやったことではないんですよ
例えば 美味しい炊き込みご飯作りまったよと言っても
自威張るなよと 自分にできたのは材料を揃えるだけなんです
それは適当な量の材料は炊飯器に入れただけ
それは私は貢献した原因で
野菜は野菜での仕事をして
チキン入れたならばチキンはチキンの仕事をして
米は米の仕事をして 電気は電気の仕事をして
水は水の仕事をして そういう様々な原因が揃ったところで
炊き込みご飯というのは結果が現れてくるんです
人間がご飯を作って どうですかね？美味しいでしょうに
私の腕はいいでしょうというふうに自慢したくなるんですね
これはちょっとおかしい
まあ冗談に自慢したってもいいんだけど
別に本来は自慢にならない
そこでこのこの実践で
この修行で この瞑想ですよ
この瞑想で 原因と条件によって結果が現れるという因果法則を単純な訓練で発見することはできます
ブッダが説かれたものすごい難しい因果法則を
こういう単純な実験で自分で発見してほしい
経験になってほしい だから
炊き込みご飯のたとえでも言ったんだから
自分にはそれほど役目はないんですよ
寿司を作りましょうと言っても
自分の役目はほんのわずかなんです
じゃあカレー作りますと言っても
自分の役目は材料を洗って切って放り込んで
水を入れて 皆様は油で揚げたりもしますけど
私ならやりませんし だから私のよりはまずいんです
で それからカレーのルーを入れるだけでしょう
だから自分がやったことはほんのわずかなんです
で 人生いつでもそうなんです
生きているんだけど 皆様に家まで帰られますよ
しかし 皆様の貢献するところは
ちょっと意欲を持つだけ
で 駅まで行ったり 左に曲がろう
右に曲がろう 階段上がるという程度なんですね
電車が来たら じゃあ入りましょう
それから電車が目的地まで運んでくれるんです
それから道があるんだからね
自分にできるのは左に曲がるとか右に曲がる程度でしょ
だから家に戻りましたよと自慢できる
あの子供みたいにただいま
すごい自慢なんですね
あれは 子供のただいまは何かすごいことをやったような感じで
まあ子供がやると可愛いんだけど
実際は大人もね ただいまと自慢げに言っちゃうと可愛いところじゃないでしょ
だから自我張らない人生が現れてくるんです
私の貢献は微々たるものだと
それも意志だけです 私でもないんです
はい 次に行きます 自我の幻覚
自我が幻覚であると見えてきます
このような修行をすると
自我って幻覚だと このからくり
この仕組みが見えてくる
眼耳鼻舌身の流れにこの実践をしてみれば
感覚を瞑想する結果で自我の錯覚が現れるのだと発見します
だからこの眼耳鼻舌身
流れあるでしょ 一つ選ぶ
耳 目 どちらでもいいです
で耳を選んだら音が触れる
感じる聴覚が生まれる
音が触れる 感じる聴覚が生まれる
音が触れる 感じる聴覚
流れなんですね 終わりがないんですね
音があるたびに感じる聴覚
感じる聴覚 感じる聴覚
あ 俺が弾いてるんじゃないかって
そのまま突然化け物が割り込んでくるんですね
あ これ単調な音だから面白くない
あ 化け物が割り込んだんです
自我が割り込んだ あ なかったのに
物の怪が割り込んだと
あ なるほど ないんだと
そこで発見するんです
過去の物語と将来の推測
期待 心から消えて 無限の自由を感じます
私たちは自由がないのは嘘の過去と希望の将来があるからなんです
どちらでも間違っています
私は将来希望したからといって何もできませんよ
だって自分が貢献する分がほんの微々たるものだから
だから将来の希望を持たない方がいいんで
はい そこから解放されます
発展のレベルに合わせて煩悩が現れなくなります
自我の物の声をどんな程度で発見したのかということで煩悩が消えるんです
物の怪の気配で感じたら
ある程度で自我が弱くなります
ある程度で怒り 欲 ちょっと低くなるだけ
物の怪がドカンと発見したらもう終わり
悟りに達しています だから修行するたびに
この自我の物の怪がなんとなく感じたり
それなりに感じたり はっきり発見したりという順番があります
はい 眼耳鼻舌身のすべての流れを調べる必要はありません
難しくなるんです 一つの流れを観察すると
自我の幻覚の発見できます
一つはやりやすいものを選んでやってみてください
例えば 座って瞑想する時は痛みとか現れるでしょうに
その時物の怪が出てきますよ
私は痛み 痛みで実況しなさいと言ってるでしょ？で
嘘でしょ 本当は痛いと気持ち持ちつつ
痛み 痛みと苦労しているでしょ
物の怪が割り込んでいるんですね
はい ブッダの言葉 ヤンプッベタンウィソーセーヒパッチャテーマーフキンチャナ
マッジェーチェーノーガヘッススシウパサントーチャリスティ
これはこの間のゴートミーの経典で解説しました
過去というものから自由になりなさい
あと 将来についても何もあってはならない
将来のことを期待することもやめるという意味なんですね
真ん中 いわゆる今現在に執着してはならない
安穏に生きてみなさいと
これはブッダがこのジャトカニという仙人が人に教えた言葉なんですね
涅槃の境地はこういうことであると
これは解脱の境地に対する説明です
難しいんですからね では私は解説します
簡単に 川が流れる 不思議なことは何も起こらないで川が流れる
いろいろ変化はあるが
すべて自然法則ですね
川の流れにいろいろ変化がありますけど
すべて自然 因縁の関係で善も悪もなく
判断する必要もなく 嫌う必要も
愛着抱く必要もありません
ん？うん じゃあ川の流れ観察しましょう
こうあってはならないと自分に権利がある
水が激しく流れてはいけませんよと
原因があって水の流れが激しくなるだけ
だから激しく流れているんだと
原因があって穏やかに流れる
穏やかに流れるんだと
ああ 今日の川の流れは良い
今日の川の流れが悪い
今日はこんな流れを期待するとか
管轄外でしょ これが生きる哲学なんです
川が流れる原因によって判断もする
石なんかに当たったら
水がずっと飛んだりもする
ただ見ればいいんです
そのまま やはり人生の場合も
生きることも なんだこれ
脳は根になってますね
何でも根になっちゃいますね
生きることも川の流れのように因縁によって生じる行為の流れです
生きるということは川の流れです
私はという何か目的があって上げたならば
だから自分の意思も一つの原因ですよ
上げた 次は下げなくちゃいけない
それだけ 因縁によって生じる行為の流れです
止まったもの何もないんです
判断も愛着も成り立たないと発見する
賢者は解脱に達します
これはお釈迦様の言葉の私の解説なんですね
悟った人っていうのは
命って川やと思っていることなんです
こちら善もないし 悪もないし
良いことも悪いこと何もない
生きているんだから歩いていく
歩くこと 足ががこんと石にぶつかる
別に見なかったんだからぶつかったんです
どうってことないんです
石にぶつかったんだから
今足に痛みが生まれてる
痛みが生まれて悪いわけじゃないんです
当然の結果なんです 見ていればいいんです
ここで主観で自我張って判断する
善悪判断する 善し悪し判断する
好みは入れる どうですかね
これっておかしいんです
病気です だから人生も生きることも物事の流れです
こちらに私がいません
お墓だけではないんです
皆様 お墓に私がいませんと思っているでしょう
こちらにも私がいます
足かせになっている過去は史実事実ではありません
自分が作った根拠のないねつ造です
我々の歴史は 将来はあなたに知ることは不可能です
将来と思っているのは
あなたの感情が作った希望期待という主観的な幻覚です
将来の幻覚です 自分の感情と希望とで幻覚作っちゃうんです
今は今というのは事実です
今はあります 今の瞬間
事実ですが 今の命は瞬間
すぐ今は消えちゃうんです
瞬間で消えるから愛着不可能です
今に愛着したいんだけど
あるんだからね でもすぐ消えますから
愛着する前に消えますよ
今は だから今は愛着する前に消えるんだったから
この愛着はどこにあるんですかね？自分の幻覚です
一切の苦しみは幻覚に支配されているからの結果です
だからお釈迦様がおっしゃった生きることは苦であるということは
言葉を変えると お前幻覚にはまっているんだよと
それだけです 幻覚を破ったら苦がないんです
終わりです はい えーと
突然終わりましたね 私はちゃんと結論はつけたんです
炊き込みご飯の話を 炊き込みご飯の話をしてくださったんですが
その時の最初の一つの原因だけという意欲とか意志というものはどこから出てくるんでしょうか
それも必要に迫られて出てくるようなものもあるような気がするし
何もなくふと現れてくるものなんでしょうか
やっぱりそれも因果法則ですよ
必要に迫られたするとわかりますけど
やっぱりその流れでもう自然法則で欲も生まれてくるんです
しかし 欲の場合は感情が増してくると
あってはならない欲まで生まれてくるんです
感情がないと自然の欲だけで終わっちゃうんです
欲というのはこの感覚から生まれるんです
感覚は心の働きなんですね
例えば何か立っていると
何か足の方が痛いという感覚が生まれる
そうすると欲が座りましょうという欲が出てきますね
そこで意欲で腰を下げて座っただけで
それから痛みが消えるのは私に関係ないんですね
痛みが消えちゃうと もう座っていることが苦しくなってくるんですね
そうするともう立ちましょうと
また意欲が生まれてくるんです
だから 意欲はそういうふうに瞬間瞬間が現れるんです
そこに感情が入っちゃうと
変な欲になる 例えば私が座るならば
この椅子に決まってるでしょ？こんなのは座りたくないとかね
もっといい椅子がないの？とこう言っちゃうと
全部壊れますね 環境が
だから感情 自我が割り込むと気持ち悪い欲になるんです
それがなければ自然法則の欲なんです
はい こんな程度でよろしいですか
ありがとうございます
はい ちょっと手を挙げて
こちらのこの大丈夫  すいません
先に今日のお話は過去は事実データではなくて
自分の録音から出てきた感情が熱動した妄想というかですね
人間の知的障害だというふうにご説明いただいてよくわかったのですが
私 一つ悩みがありまして
ブッダの教えの中で いわゆる仏典というんですか
神話だと私は思って 多分ノイズだというふうに自分では理解していたんですけど
ジャータカっていうのがありますよね
これはブッダの 浄土される前に
何代にもわたって輪廻転生をされていたというお話なんですが
このジャータカの中にある輪廻転生のお話
それからパーリ中部に天師教というのがあって
この中には死後世界のですね
六道五道輪廻という話があって
地獄の階層が六道 地獄から天国までの階層が 6つ
5つあるというようなお話が天師教にあると
それから これは直接今のお話とは関係ない話なんですが
スッタニパータの中には三十二相経と
またセーラー教というのがあって
ブッダの人柄 人相ですね
これが事細かく語られているというのが
いろいろブッダの教えを読んでいく中で出てきまして
こういうお話と その これは当然ブッダが成道される前の過去が絡んでいるわけですが
ダンマパダ等アーガマの中にですね
輪廻とか それからその不変の魂というか
アートがですね こういったものは柔軟無期という言葉の中で
ブッダ自身は肯定も否定もされてないと
不起ということですから
こだわらないと そこはまあ
昔のインドの古い仏教以前のですね
伝説の中にもあったということで
肯定も否定もされなかったというふうに記憶しているわけですが
そういうお話と そのブッダの
このいわゆる無明を克服する合理的なですね
科学的な諸行無常と諸法無我のお話と
その一見 その何て言うんですか
古代の神話のようなジャータカとかですね
それからスッタニパータの中とか
パーリ中部にある三十二相経とか
製作経とかですね 典史教というのの
何か史実と事実で合理的に判断されているブッダの教えと
そういうお話が私の中でどうも腑に落ちてこないと
だからその私にとってはどちらかというとノイズであると
明らかにですね その典史教とかですね
三十二相経とかセーラー教ですね
そういうふうに理解していたんですけども
この点について長老からですね
もう少し腑に落ちるようなご説明いただければなと
こういうふうに思っています
どちらがそれか自分で判断すれば
だからずっと仏教はそういうふうに伝統的にガチャガチャガチャガチャガチャガチャ言うだけで
誰一人にも具体的に科学的にブッダがこれを教えたんだよと
解脱はこれだよと言えないでしょう
学者には だって 1分ぐらいでも慈悲の瞑想すらしたことがない学者の方々だから
だからこの学者の方々は
学者の基準によって研究しているんでしょうし
で 私たちはこのやってみる世界の話
今しているんです だから
日本でくだらない仏教で私も納得したならば
私は日本にいる必要はなかったんです
私はものすごい楽なんですよ
国に帰ったならば この年になっとる
ものすごい大物になっていたんだと思います
大統領でも政治家でもビビる
若い時で私のことをビビっていたんだからね
だからもう最悪 私の場合は
でもなんで日本で止まったのかというと
これは仏教ではないんですね
やっているのは だからこんな素晴らしい宝物
人間知らずしていいんですかというと
一緒なんです だから皆様
伝統的に皆様は知識人だからたくさん本を読んでいらっしゃいますよ
それは素晴らしいことですけど
その学者が書いている本にあるストーリーと
もう一つ 修行者たちの間でもう一つストーリーがあるんです
それは今紹介しているんです
修行者のストーリーは大学ではないんです
一回私は大学仕事をしている場合は
私の先生たちと私はこの授業の内容を書いて出さなくちゃいけないです
それである先生がもうあなた方
若者もいるんだから この修行の世界も授業の内容に入れましょうかと言ったら
先生断りますと 私は断ったんです
大学ではごちゃごちゃごちゃ文献調べたりしてやってくださいと
これは言葉にならないものは
私は授業をやりたくないんだと
瞑想について授業をやって
学生に点数をあげると
いい加減にしてくださいと
私は断ったんだから捨てられましたけどね
そういうことでストーリー 2つあります
まあ以上ですよ 私の答えは
だから 例えばお釈迦の先生物語
その通りに信じるならばどうぞ
否定したければどうぞ
どうでもいいんです しかし
私もたまたまジャータカ物語は参考にします
その時 私はどのように参考するのかと
それ勉強してください
見方が違います 私はインド文化系の人間だから
物語のありがたみよく知っています
どんな難しい理論も このキツネさんに頼むと
ウサギさんに頼むと すごいわかりやすく教えてくれるんです
だからインド文化はストーリーですごい難しい論理を理解するんです
例えばリーダー 一つ参考に出します
リーダーが 政治家がどんな気持ちで
どんな心構えで国民を統治するべきかという疑問が現れるでしょう
本どれぐらい読めばいい？切りがないです
西洋ではもうこれ膨大な学問でしょ
政治学っていうのは博士までありますよ
博士たち腐るほどいるんですよ
役に立たん では 仏教ではちょっとした物語を言います
ある森に猿の群れがいたんです
この猿の群れのボス猿がいたんです
体格が良くて 群れの人々をすごく心配する
立派なボス猿がいたんです
だから 何か知らない食い物を見つけたら
すぐ食うんじゃなくて
私に見せてくださいとかね
私が許可出したら食べてくださいとか
そんな程度です そこであの森が山火事になったんです
そうすると このボス猿がみんなで一緒に死にましょうではないんです
あ 私がボスだから 私の群れを守る義務は私にあるんだと
そこで幅広い川があったんです
川向こうには山火事は行かない
じゃあ 私の群れを川の向こうに持っていけば
自分の国民が守られる
国民じゃなくて群れが守られると
でも川があまりも深くて
子供たちが泳げない お母さんたちが子供を抱っこして泳げない
年寄りもいる これ大変です
じゃあどうしようかと思って
自分のそばにいろいろアドバイスするもう一つのオス猿がいたんです
そいつに 川の幅を計算しなさいと
で ボス猿も川の幅を計算したんです
計算して この長さの大きな鶴を持ってきて
ボス猿持ってきたんです
長さを計算して 鶴を持ってきたんです
持ってきて 二人の仕事だから
猿は自分の腰に鶴をつなげる
家来の猿にお前が 木にしっかり縛っておいてくださいと言っちゃうと
こいつは木にツルを縛る前にちょっとかじったんです
かじって一つ ほんのちょっとぐらい切っちゃったんです
いわゆる 10センチぐらい短くしたんです
それで縛ってあげたんです
そこでボス猿が川の向こうに飛んだんです
飛んだらこれ短いんですね
自分の計画は 木にツルを結んで
川の向こうの木にもツルを結んで猿たちを渡ってもらう
そうすると子供たちを渡れます
枝は捕まったんだけど
どうするもない それでボス猿が言うんです
君たちが私のことを心配しないで
みんなさっさと渡ってくださいと
私は体力あるんだから捕まっておこうそうと
そこで猿たちがもうボスの体の上はもう行ってはいけません
失礼ですけど すいません
すいませんと謝りながら
川の向こうに行って命拾いをする
あの係のあのオス猿が最後に行くんで
こいつは体力もあるんです
こいつは狙っていたんです
このボス猿の体力はもうギリギリまでなくなるまで
猿たちが渡って渡って渡って
最後にこいつはゴツンゴツンとツルを渡るんですね
渡って この猿はもうどうしようもないでしょ
また山火事のところに戻るか
そのまま死ぬかしかないんですね
それで やっぱり猿は頭がいいんだから
手を外しちゃうと大丈夫ですよ
川に落ちるだけ 落ちたっても死なない
するがあるんだから それから泳げばいいんだから
これ何とかしようと思って
あの最後に行った猿が
こいつの胸の辺り カチッとかいたんです
かいて肉の一つ取ってしまったんです
行って向こうに行ったんです
行って自分がボスになるんです
そこでこの菩薩猿がそこで亡くなるんです
このストーリーで何を教えていますか？政治家が国民のために命は捨てても構いませんという話でしょ
それでも どんな立派な政治家にも汚いことをやっている連中がうろうろしているんだよと
だから完全たる正しい政治をやっても
身の回りも気をつけなさいと
しかし 国民のために命を捨てなさいよというエピソードでしょ
だから これ本当にお釈迦様が過去世で猿でいたかないか
私に関係ないんです 知らない
私にとっては あのストーリーが
あの猿の物語が 分厚いテキストをたくさん読んでも理解できないことを一発で教えてくれるんです
だから私もガバナンスというし
ちょっと西洋の本とかなめたことあるんだけど
面白くない 汚い よく政治家使う本がありますよ
プリンスという本 あれ
マキアヴェリが書いたね
汚いそのものでしょ マキアヴェリの本なんか
みんなそれはテキストで使っているんです
いわゆる国民騙せ 仏教的には弱く命投げなさいと
そういうふうに このジャータカ物語は
我々には素晴らしい生き方を教えているんですよ
これで頭でっかちの学者の方々は
こんな話認められませんとかね
ブッダは過去でそんなことは後で書いた
後で書いたってもいいんじゃない？別に
そういうものなんですよ
それからこのじゃあ一つの経典にある
このあれ 輪廻六道の話は
それは生命の次元のことで
それはそのまま事実ですよ
これはちょっと生命のことを理解すれば
変な科学を捨ててね 生命は心がいろいろ次元を取ることわかります
で 次元 心のレベルによって肉体が現れます
それは一般人にわからないんだからといって捨てるわけにはいきません
わからないんだったら黙っていなさいというしかないんです
で 私が死んじゃったら
次はどんな肉体を作るのかという
このその時の心の状況なんです
だからそれは犬になるかどうか
それから魂の話ね それは学者の勘違いで
仏教ははっきりと魂は存在するはずもないと説かれています
それは学者にわからないのはどうか
私がわかりません 無我論でなければ仏教は成り立ちません
無常でなければ仏教すら成り立たないんです
一切現象は無常であると説かれたら
無我以外何でもないでしょうに
無常苦無我と言ってるでしょうに
面白いですよ すごい一生人生かけて研究する学者の方々に
これは目に入らないんですね
それは私の問題ではありません
はい だからだからといって
そういう知識のために勉強するのは構いませんよ
私はテキストから 学者のテキストからね
論文から読み取るない
しかし ブッダの生の言葉から読み取る真理を発表しているんです
これはまあ 私に頼めば
大学の一つの授業にすることはできます
が それはいらない だから一般的に喋ってはいるんです
話は以上です  時間にはなりましたけど
手を挙げた方がいらっしゃるので
ちょっと最後にお願いします
ありがとうございます
ちょっと難しい話はなかなか分からないけど
先ほど度を超えた自我が精神病にはなるというお話がありまして
今日実は妻が一緒に来るつもりだったんですけれども
かなり 10年来ぐらい躁鬱病という
患ってまして それで躁鬱になると
自分のことをものすごく傷つけるという言葉がどんどんどんどん出てきて
それが親についても小さい頃こんなこと言われた
ダメだって言われたというのが連続して出てきて
それがなかなか治らないというような状況が続いてね
それで今のお話の中で
度を超えた自我ということが関係があるのかどうか分かりませんが
そういう度を超えて自分を傷つけていくようなものが身近にいる場合に
どのように接していったらいいのか
それから精神病というのはなかなか治りにくい病気に受け取られたんですけども
長老のお立場からして
そういう病にかかった人にどういう風に接して
あるいは普通の家族なりなんなりができることって一体何なのか
ちょっと個人的な話で申し訳ないんですけれども
教えていただけますか
えーとですね これ難しいんですよ
この度を越した自我っていうのは
自分で気づかない自我なんですね
だから普通 常識的な人々はみんな自我ですよ
でも 自我があることを知っているんですね
みんな自我張ってますよ
みんな喧嘩しているんですね
傷ついたり 落ち込んだり
ハチャメチャなんですね
だからしかし 自分に自我あることは知っている
この時々 あまりにも自我が巨大で見えない場合があるんですね
富士山に乗ったら富士山見えないでしょ？だからこのそこで病気になっちゃうんですね
だからこのカオンスラマ方々は
それってあなたの自我でしょ？それってあなたの自我でしょう？という風にずっとフィードバックしなくちゃいかんですね
向こうは否定しまくるんです
例えば私の悪口言っている
別に言われたってもいいでしょ
あんた自我があるんだから
それ嫌がってるでしょ
実は私の悪口をみんな言ってますけど
私は気にしませんと それで向こうは怒るんです
あなたとは違いますよとかね
それは自我でしょとかね
そうやってこの長い時間かけて
この壊れた脳が治るまで
自我に気づいてほしいんですよ
自分も相当傲慢な自我だなと分かったら
ほとんど治ってはいるんですね
時間かかる難しい作業なんです
で 病気な方はもう一方的に否定して否定していくんです
それも病気の一つの症状なんですね
だから治療人を否定する目的で治療に行くんだだから普通の病気と質が悪いんですね
私の場合はお腹が痛くてたまらない
その時 私はお医者さんのところに行って
先生お願いしますから薬ちょうだいと
薬もらったらありがたくて感謝しながら薬飲むんですね
精神的な病気の方は逆なんですね
治療するなよと 私はこういうことだからしょうがないでしょうと
あの時々 あの状況を緩和するために薬あげるでしょ
精神の場合でも脳を抑えてあげる
それすら否定するんです
それで興奮しちゃって
暴れちゃって 喧嘩しちゃって
人殺しにまで行ったりするんだけど
医者がもう落ち着く 精神安定剤あげると嫌ですと言うんです
そういう風な この精神病気の場合は
ものすごい立ち入り難いという
いろいろあるんですね
私もわからない どうすればいいかというね
だから ご自分でちょっとした何か問題あるなと思ったら
まあ別に気にしないでください
それは自我張りすぎやと思ってください
それから私の仏教的な次のレッスンは
自我る必要ないんだと
みんな怯えて生活しているんだと
あんただけじゃないんだと
誰にも自信がないんだよと
だからあなたも負けてもいいし
勝ってもいいし バカにされてもいいし
褒められてもどうでもいいや
そんなのはと 普通の人間がやっていることみたいにやってみてくださいと
あなたは 世界はうまくいってるのに
私はうまくいってないというのあなたの自我だよと
世界はうまくいってないんです
誰も みんなもう傷だらけでもう戦っているんです
貶されるわ 褒められるわ
失敗するわ たまに成功するわ
収入が入っても足らないわね
頑張ってますよ ただ あれほど自我がないんだから
まあしょうがないということで落ち着くんです
自我が度越しちゃうと
まあしょうがないで終わらないんですね
攻撃する なんでそうなるのかと
なんで私をバカにするのかということになっちゃうんです
それで社会に攻撃できない場合は
自分で何か精神的な病気を作るんですね
それはプログラムですよ
だからなかなかわからない
でも 書く人があまり暗い話も良くないんだからね
自分が精神的な ちょっと異常な問題があるなと思ったら
気にしないことまず 誰だって精神的に完成ではないんですね
といっても 何といいますか
ダメで元々という感じで普通に生きてみるんです
それで治りますよ 私たちは瞑想プログラムを持ってますけど
やってくれないんですね
言ってもこういう単純なものを動かすことでは治りますよ
ものを動かしてみる 手を上げて下げてみる
あるいは歩く瞑想をやってみる
そういうことで だいたい 1週間で治ります
やらないでしょ 精神病気は何であろうともね
あのひどくなって もう脳も壊れているならばもうアウトですから
それはしょうがないんだけど
まあある程度のいろんなガチャガチャのコンプレックスというのはね
それってだいたい 1週間
2週間の歩く瞑想で治ります
でも 歩く瞑想の場合は
自我を置いておいて やりづらいことはよく覚悟してやらなくてはいけないんですね
特に精神的な人は 妄想は激しいんだから
妄想をストップする実況中継っていうのは結構厳しいんですよ
そういうふうに やっぱりいろいろハンディが生まれてはきますが
理論的には治ります ティーエティカルには治ります
実際治療を施すと 受け入れられないという
はプラクティカルは起きますね
はい 以上です  ではだいぶ時間が過ぎてしまいましたので
これで本日の講義は終了したいと思います
はい 一緒に唱えましょう
ドゥッカパッタチェニン
ドゥッカ バヤン パッタチェニン
バヤソウカンパッタチェニッソウカホントゥサンレピパニノ
苦しんでいる悩む生命が苦しみなく
恐れて悩む生命が恐れなく
悲しんで悩む生命が悲しみなく
一切の生命が安穏でありますように
はい どうもありがとうございます